my guilt hey youtubers it's Charlie and
by popular demand here's my Game of
Thrones Season 4 preview for Brienne of
Tarth it's also as of posting this video
George RR Martin's official birthday be
sure to send him an email telling him
not to kill your favorite character
because he can't refuse any requests on
his birthday or is that his daughter's
wedding day I don't think he has a
daughter let's roll the dice on that one
but like I said in my previous Game of
Thrones season 4 preview videos spoiler
warning for everything from seasons 1 2
3 and a mild spoiler warning for the
beginning of feast for crows Brienne is
one of my favorite characters on Game of
Thrones she didn't really start out that
way when I was reading the books when
she and Jamie started having their
scenes together I really felt like it
was more about Jamie and focused more on
him but as Gwendoline Christie and
Nikolaj coster-waldau started working on
the show basically most of those scenes
started to turn more into Brienne story
that Jamie just happened to be passing
through think of it like in Star Wars it
being this small r2 unit story as he
kind of runs into all these Jedi Masters
and tries to kind of Chronicle the
history of the galaxy over like a 70
year span he's totally gonna be in
episode 7 don't you just feel sometimes
like Brienne is the last good thing in
Westeros like she has this really pure
dream that she's really open about all
she ever wanted to be was a knight she
basically wants to be like in the
Kingsguard defending her king and the
realm but when in reality the Kingsguard
is just full of a bunch of cheats and
liars but she sticks to her guns even
when she gets dragged through the mud
and a few bear pits and takes Jaime back
to King's Landing obviously some of her
sense of honor and Duty rubbed off on
Jaime in that most epic bath scene ever
seen in fandom but I think she's going
to get a much more independent storyline
in season 4 after the first few episodes
so let's follow up on the season 3
finale where we left Brienne and Jaime
they basically just arrived at King's
Landing and said their goodbyes but what
is Brienne going to do now that she's in
King's Landing all she wants to be as
the knight and they probably aren't
going to let her join the Kingsguard
just because it's a bit of a boys club
so what is she going to do next
obviously she needs another quest there
are a few things to address before
that happens though so there is one big
plot point that Brennan needs to wrap up
before she can kind of move on and take
on her next quest if you remember in
season two he was one of the last people
to see Renly alive so she basically got
blamed for his murder along with Catelyn
Stark
and everyone who doesn't understand the
magic of that situation still thinks
she's a murderer including Renly's
boyfriend Loras who just happens to be
in King's Landing getting ready to marry
Cersei though based on that they
obviously have to wrap up that storyline
so I think Jaime and Brienne will get
some more scenes together in the first
couple of episodes I don't know if it'll
be the first episode or the second or
the third I don't think that Brienne
will be in every single episode but
obviously Jaime is going to have to
rescue her from another bear pit this
time the bear pit is Loras
chronologically since they've already
changed so much about Bereans storyline
from the books we have to talk about a
few things that are probably going to
happen so let me know what you think of
my timeline here I think this is how
it's gonna go down here's where we also
need to talk about a few more specific
spoilers from the end of book 3 and the
beginning of book 4 so careful for that
so remember the whole point of brans
quest and bringing Jaime back to King's
Landing was to trade for Sansa and Arya
everyone else still kind of thinks
they're in King's Landing but because
Sansa storyline kind of diverges in the
books even though that's already changed
a few things are gonna get a little bit
fuzzy so this is why I think the
timeline is going to change in this way
in the books by the time Brienne makes
it back to King's Landing with Jaime
Sansa has already fled so there are no
stark girls in King's Landing that's why
she ends up having to go on her next
quest to try and find them for catland
but because the show has changed that
now I think what's going to happen is
there's going to be a big mega spoilery
event then Sansa will leave then Brienne
will be ordered to bring her back so
here's five chronological events that I
think are going to lead to Brienne's
new quest once she deals with a very
very pissed-off Loras - she doesn't
really get any scenes for a couple of
episodes which kind of sucks three mega
spoilery event I will not discuss here
for Sansa flees to the Vale with
Littlefinger and then five brilliant is
ordered to bring her back someone is
going to tell Brienne that Sansa has
been kidnapped and on her honor she has
to bring Sansa back and rescue her let
me know what you think of my timeline
there I think that's the way it's gonna
go down based on the way things have
changed chronologically from the
to the show remember if you've read
ahead a lot of that's going to be
invalidated now although I think a lot
of the big events will still happen I
still think she's gonna get Oathkeeper
so let me know you think since so many
of you have requested him my next game
of Thrones Season 4 preview will be for
Stannis that video will post on Monday
be sure to subscribe to get it
obviously after that I have to do
Melisandre they come as a pair as always
be sure to write in the comments and let
me know which characters you want to
talk about next I'll be sure to add them
to my list I also just posted a very
special giveaway to say thank you to all
of you for subscribing to my channel and
helping you get so big so fast you can
click here to watch that or you can
click here to watch all my other Game of
Thrones season 4 preview videos thank
you so much remember Legend for tonight
see you guys later
high fives
you